can you guys hear me
i think you guys can hear me all right
alhamdulillah
that's probably better you guys could
probably hear me better now inshallah
how's everyone you guys doing good
inshaallah
all right
i answered this like 11 times in the
last stream the podcast with hamza insha
allah will drop in a few weeks
okay insha allah
for the patrons on patreon i posted the
link there this is kind of last minute
so i think it'll do inshallah
i just put the link up
so
i expect to see a few people in here in
a bit for the
patrons
i mean
is this live live yes this is live live
mr hippo mr hippo this is live live
all right
bismillah
it's gonna be like this for a little bit
man i'm i stole the show i'm running the
show now alhamdulillah it's going to be
like this for a little bit why is it so
bright
are
busy
okay
this is a full takeover this is the full
blown takeover of the channel
the link
is currently only for patrons on patreon
i might
decide to put it somewhere else i don't
know if i can on youtube this was kind
of like a last minute thing for me so i
just put on patreon
uh
you know what i'll put it in the chat
for a little bit before i delete the
comment
just for the early commerce
i'll put it i'll put up for a little bit
and then i'll delete it
they're busy adventuring yes yes
normally rami is missing outside and not
homeless
that's funny that's funny
i don't like i don't like to think that
i'm normally missing i think most of the
time i'm here
but i guess when someone's missing
sometimes
most of the time maybe
let's put that aside man let's move on
the one muslim
t1m t1m
the one muslim
um it's a bit cold it's getting warmer
alhamdulillah have a debate with shias i
don't think that's really
worth it to be honest
all right we're starting to get a lot of
people in here now alhamdulillah so let
me
can i remove the comments
all right i don't know where i went but
i'm back now i can't really remove my
own comment i don't think without
blocking myself
so i guess it's gonna stay up there we
have
one two three four five six seven eight
people in here i think eight people
alhamdulillah um can i
get a quick show of the people in the
audience just so i see that you're
actually
you know people normal people not
lunatics
just to make sure
if you can turn on your camera turn it
on because i can see you guys quickly
um i won't put you on the stream if you
don't want your camera on on stream but
for my
sake
i have to do my due diligence
all right all right okay two two people
listen
two people
uh
why can't i delete comments
i don't know why i can't but anyways
let's bring people on insha allah
i'm just going to go down the list so
sister the head lover i'm going to bring
you one i don't know if you want a
camera on it or not but it's up to you
all right
all right
so what brings you on the show
today i just enjoy you know watching
some youtubers now days like
i think you know
like i learned a lot i guess
i'm watching them
i know we're the best channel out there
of course so you when you say them
you're talking about us for sure um
i'm just joking
i'm just saying i just think
it's okay
so is that all you you came on to say
that
you get benefit out of out of some
youtube videos
i mean
that's great
so like
i love this you were this were you the
sister that talked about starting her
own podcast and stuff
yeah i actually went on stereo and i did
a little like
are you like shy
embarrassed of it yeah i got like the
worst first audience like this is not
the beauty should be given to some
reason
we got into arguments like i had to
explain like a lot of things
it's okay oh it was bad like i even like
i was praying afterwards and i gave my
mother like oh my god i just did that
in my mother yeah yeah yeah i know i i
feel you there unfortunately that
happens
to the best of us so
it's okay you know
the first one not the last one
insha'allah if you i don't even remember
what my first i actually i remember what
my first discussions were like they
weren't recorded or on any kind of
radius or anything
but they were
at school sometimes on a field trip
you know i know i could have done better
but it's just how it is in the beginning
so keep going insha'allah may allah
grant you strength
and uh basically all of us died
all of us friends
a lot of people like bummed out and
for the current events and stuff yeah i
guess i want you guys to have hope like
that's what religion promotes like it's
not the end of time
yeah
i don't know when then the times are
going to be
everybody just chill like
no vibes i'm a minnesotan
so we're all vibes here
well when your podcast drops inshallah
you can come back and let us know
and uh we'll we'll give it a shout out
oh my god so i'll be contacting you in
2024
whenever it's whenever it's up and
running let us know
all right can someone else come in for
you yeah don't worry i'll i'll boot you
off
um i'm going to bring someone else on in
the second insha'allah
allah bless you
for coming on you can come on many times
more in the future insha'allah
but uh
we'll talk soon
[Music]
all right next we have khabib
assalamu alaikum
it's great to be on man i'm a big fan of
the channel
you know it's crazy because on hill
right he had that his own youtube
channel yeah and uh i was just following
his channel over the years you know
because there's always like a lot of
like uplifting and uh accountability and
you know ways for men to you know
improve
so when i seen him uh do that video i
was like subhanallah you know that's
crazy allows one of the guys you know
yeah
but um yeah the big fan of the channel
like uh what's what's some plans for the
future that you guys have like
for like the channel i mean for the
plans for the future for the channel
um well we want to drop some merch
that's for sure um the long awaited
episode with hamza that everyone keeps
asking about 11 times the stream uh it's
going to come in a few weeks but that
was it
uh what's his name
no no we already had one with hamza
sources oh yeah yeah yeah he was a good
guest though yeah yeah he was amazing
we had him for two episodes actually
alhamdulillah
but hamza if you watch our most recent
or one of our most recent videos we we
talk about hamza we react to a video he
made and we basically announced he's
coming on the podcast insha allah so
that's good
we're gonna like i said we're gonna
launch some merch i'm also gonna drop a
website insha'allah and uh maybe a
discord in the future as well that's
again it's gonna be sick a lot of people
are on there you know i mean on there a
couple channels
but um
this is a random question but like you
know the last sister like talk about the
end times and stuff you know so i had a
debate with my colleagues and i was like
you know subhanallah look around like
what more do we need to see to like for
the end times to come you know yeah
obviously we don't know that but like he
was bringing example because you know
like the mongols were killing the
muslims once upon a time you know
because those muslims must have been
like oh this this this is the end times
you know it's like muslim bodies stacked
and like beheaded and stuff so i don't
know but like
like these days like i feel like you
know just society's crumbling you know
yeah yeah for sure for sure you know
i don't think i don't think a society
like ours is um sustainable
yeah i don't think a capitalistic
society is sustainable bro
yeah exactly and like the
it's it's all unfolding you know like we
have so many uh
um like humanitarian problems there's
like reverse select like not we're not
selective but like the media is very
selective what they show and the outrage
and like the agendas they you know
start and stuff so it's kind of crazy
yeah yeah but i guess it's just more
more um
you know reminders for us that you know
our time is limited and you know and
just make the best and don't be uh
like discouraged you know a believer
always has uh
allah with him and you know we have
guidance so subhanallah you know should
be thankful
yeah yeah
yeah man i don't want to take too much
time off the stream but uh appreciate
you having me on by the brother
and what you said is true bro 100 but
it's just
unfortunately it's what you know allah
just wanted to happen that these people
could be given to power we muslims lost
it they got it muslims will get it back
eventually and we just have to
complacent though you know worldwide
like saudi the way they're
we think that would be like the ideal
you know like this that's the that's the
homeland that's the mecca
like them they're dropping bombs on
yemen so it's like what's going on yeah
allah will hold them accountable exactly
yep
yeah we we've we've had some we've even
had bad islamic leaders in history
yeah over the past thirteen hundred
years for fourteen hundred years we've
had bad decent leaders and you know what
it is uh like uh the biggest like like
one of the greatest jihad right is like
against our nups right that's like what
it comes down to individually because we
sometimes we want to like
act like the world's collapsing so we
can't you know be control like of
ourselves but we have to you know place
our own family and inner circles we
should uh
do good as best as i can but as best we
can though yeah
sound like a brother i appreciate you uh
having me on and uh i look forward to
the future podcast hi
good brother
all right
first mr jones you're a bad boy i put
you in a timeout
and now i'm gonna have to block you
because you went from being a bad boy to
being a delinquent
yes you're a delinquent you young man
delinquent i have to block you now
shame on you
anyways brother hashim i'm going to
bring you on inshaallah if you're ready
you're good
all right
yes
well i can sit down after how are you
i'm more good bro i can't apologize it's
all dark it's like
it's very dark
let me get a bit more lighting
yeah oh sorry it's my ipad isn't it
yeah
cool
welcome bro look here i like your
sweater mashallah it's very nice i
appreciate it of course bro welcome to
the stream
yo
i actually just came on to be honest on
the whim
um i came from work and it's like nearly
11 30 in the uk so
i'm pretty tired but
i don't really have much to ask really
just wanted to say keep up what you're
doing
you know appreciate what you're doing
for the dawg for the um you know it's
all good i appreciate a lot i don't tune
in every week unfortunately because life
gets very busy but it's good that you
keep doing what you need to do in it so
yeah
it means a lot may allah bless you
uh may allah reward you and uh what kind
of work you went to man
um
to be honest i do a lot of freelance
type of stuff yeah i'm technically an
animator
by night because during the day i work
uh corporate pretty corporate job um but
that's what i do really in my free time
i'm trying to make a sustainable living
from it and
i'm technically in the process of making
a short film
that is technically a bit that way
involved
it's not easy because it's animation and
there's a lot of you know controversy
around it with how to do it how to
portray it um so of course i have my
reasons why the is the outlook but as
well i want to find
some kind of some form of shade so that
i can in the future
use it as a form of educating people by
islam you know i found it very inspiring
that not many people do it
but there's a gap that needs to be
filled so
a lot of information can be shared quite
simply with visual storytelling and it
doesn't have to be very graphic it
doesn't have to be very um
i think a better way to be
like
you can kind of say contributing
a better word probably is like very
depicting very stereotypical very
very dumb you want to make sure it's a
bit engaging intellectually as well as
very spiritually as well so that's
basically it yeah it's not easy but i'm
that's my journey right now i'll
definitely update you in the future but
that's it i'm excited for it man
insha'allah when you when you finish
your short film bro send me the uh send
me the link
no no problem no problem but keep doing
what you're doing and i appreciate all
your efforts i mean do you normally do
these things well how regular
um i think at least at least once a week
we should have a call and if not then
every a bi-weekly or something like that
oh that makes sense that makes sense all
right then cool i'm gonna leave you two
in charlotte i gotta sleep
i gotta let you bro talk to me thank you
so a few things uh firstly uh
for the uh
five dollars i'm not a muslim is a
crescent
a and star a symbol of islam or is it
just a turkish symbol islamic countries
and communities used to identify
themselves it is a symbol that i believe
the ottoman empire just kind of started
using it's not an islamic symbol at all
islam doesn't have any symbol
i i honestly i wouldn't even say that
the crescent star in
the crescent in star is is a symbol of
islam
it's not
as far as i know it's not there's no
such thing for the prophet nothing from
allah to allah nothing in the quran
nothing from the prophet muhammad peace
upon that says
that this is the symbol we don't have
any symbol as muslims we worship one god
alone
and we we obey him
but it's very beautiful question masha
allah again thank you for the super chat
and again thank you for the question
all right
all right and guys if you came on and
you're not coming on again you can leave
the uh
you can leave the uh what's it called
the waiting room and just watch on
youtube normally inshallah i don't wanna
like i don't want to become too full
um
but we have someone
uh basically named jesus is god so uh i
assume that they're gonna be respectful
my friend if as long as you're
respectful we'll engage in discussion if
you're not respectful i will happily
kick you off
so hopefully it doesn't come to that but
i'm going to assume the best
hello
hey i can't i can't hear you right now
say something bro uh hi hey bro okay now
i can hear you how are you doing man i'm
a christian so i'm respectful okay okay
that's good bro that's good i appreciate
it
so how we should engage this because i
know uh we don't have much time
uh should you challenge christianity or
should i challenge islam well why we
gotta challenge each other man why can't
we just talk about this
one of us is true but both of us uh both
of us can be true or both fast as false
there's three options one of us is true
both of us are false but we can't be
both right so okay you want to challenge
christianity or challenge islam well i
mean you came on so i'll let you you
know kind of make the first uh first
strike if that's what you want to call
it man no problem no problem i have a
this
argument that i present against uh
the veracity of the claims of islam
is based on the fact that if you're not
able to link
the cause to the effect
the creator the creation
then you cannot be called the creator so
in other words
give me a second here
okay
for a second and then you turn your
camera on when you're ready
all right
all right anyways
yeah he's
i mean we don't want to be rude
he he was a bit kind of like you know
debating when he came on i don't mind
bro i do this all the time it's okay it
is what it is
uh it's not going to be long maybe a few
minutes i'll let him make a point i'll
make a point and then we'll just
kind of end it off after i think he's
ready to come back
after that brief interruption all right
thank you
so so basically what you're going to
have to do is
two steps number one explain to me where
god is because our god inhabits eternity
so for him to engage with temporal space
he has to pierce or stretch out the
heavens or the eternal reality uh as per
uh first samuel
second samuel no first time no second
samuel 22 10. so basically it says he
stretches out the heavens his eternal
reality as for isaiah 57 15
and he projects himself he sends a light
as for genesis one through let the light
be who is the son of god okay okay okay
now you wanna finalize
so
so so basically
temporal space
is
uh distinguished from the eternal
reality which god inhabits so the first
thing i need to know is where your god
is
and second i need to know how does he
engage with temporal space because if he
does not engage with time and space then
he cannot be the creator okay okay so
are you saying the way that because you
first you mentioned that if you can't
link the the cause to the effect then
you can't call yourself the creator are
you trying to say that if god has no
effect or cause or anything in this
temporal space what he called the
universe then he can't be the creator of
it right if he doesn't have a
tangible link between time and space i
mean uh time and tangible link with
creation
then he cannot have created you i know
you guys use x nihilo
yes
we said the same thing ex nil he created
out of nothing but
we say that our god is an eternity
and he created by his word by projecting
his light from his eternal reality
therefore temporal space was created
outside of eternity so that's what you
need to do you need to show me in the
narrative of islam
the link between your god where he's at
first
and temporal space okay where did
temporal space come from yeah okay so
first and foremost allah he says
the most merciful ascended above the
throne so we believe that if there's a
highest point
of or there basically if you want to
call the highest point and some take it
literally some taking murder for
metaphorically but regardless we say
allah is above the throne above the
arash the allah has a throne that's
above everything else he's above the
throne that's what we believe the
ashraes believe it's metaphorical and
they they say that allah doesn't exist
in any space
authorities they say that he's he's
above the throne
i'll say that
either or in my opinion both are valid
islamically they both valid opinions now
secondly i mean it's very
straightforward to be honest allah he
does not exist within the realm of the
universe but he created it and his
impact on it is that which is as uh
the one who doesn't need anything from
anyone but everything that exists
depends on him so god can affect
everything by will
he says
and he owns the temporal space
okay so how about this how would we
engage because you brought to the
different narratives
establish the one that says that your
god inhabits the throne that's and i
didn't say space because our god is
spiritual so the metaphysics does not
apply to uh temporal space so it's
something outside of temporal space and
if he's engaging with temporal space
it's something spiritual like or like
energy or
light is not a material thing uh is
non-matter or heat or radio waves so i'm
using examples that it doesn't have to
be a
material uh interaction i mean
we have to be careful with the words
that we're using because light or you
can still describe it as a physical
thing like they're they are photons they
are waves but they're not like
metaphysical so i i get what you're
trying to say i just wanted
i'm saying is metaphysical i'm saying
that when we're talking about god it's
metaphysical and when i'm using an
example
light radio waves if you don't want to
accept light because i believe light is
a non-matter according to all scientists
but
we're not going to argue that defects
though radio waves frequencies heat
matter okay so we don't have to use
material
language to uh
explain the engagement between god and
his creation okay so is that being said
but that being said um so let's say your
god does engage with creation um
can you explain to me because we have a
second proposition which demonstrates
the narrative of christianity is the
true narrative because
our god says he humbles himself which
means to conceal his power so it is the
concealment of his power for him to
engage with temporal space because he is
eternal and eternal cannot be mingled
with temporal space so whatever this
throne is and your god is supposed to
sustain creation
you have to show me the concealment of
his power in order order for him to um
to uh sustain creation
creation like was he in the bush
that's that's okay i just want to point
out first and foremost that's fallacious
and
before that you would have to prove why
that kind of a narrative is true that
god has why god has to humble himself in
order to sustain the temporals i said
conceal it i said i said what humble
means to conceal conceal the power i
know but why does god i what do you mean
when you say that exactly
uh well if you say he doesn't conceal
there's multiple problems
i'm asking when you say he conceals his
power what does that mean does that mean
he has infinite power but he's not
always using all of it like no no no no
no no
consume it
i don't have to give you a whole
elaborate explanation
i know let me let me explain to you let
me explain to you the word concealment
explain is self-explanatory i don't have
to give you all the uh the the specifics
to conceal something is to hide it
right uh not necessarily concealment
means to not allow it to overwhelm
like you have you believe your god is
cover his light is covered by veil yeah
that's that's a hijab still the covering
though
so let's use that illustration so our
god the concealment means that his
eternal power eternality temporal space
cannot engage one would overwhelm the
other eternality multiplied by temporal
space becomes
overwhelmed
by eternality so our god says he
conceals the son of god is the
concealment of the father okay i see
so you need to explain to me now for him
to engage or to sustain creation you
have to show me this concealment in the
narrative if you don't show me that okay
again actually
two two reasons why your narrative is
flood okay so i'm gonna explain why
that's actually fallacious now in a
better way that's gracious because
you're using a false dichotomy now
either we have to prove that god humbles
himself in a way that like perhaps he
becomes a man and humbles himself to
conceal some kind of power or
or the or the other part of the false
dichotomy
is that our way is wrong because god
cannot be eternal
and mingle in temporal space why is it
impossible that an all-powerful
unlimited god exists outside of temporal
space but has full say and control over
it
first of all i want to make it clear i
wasn't talking about the incarnation or
the so-called incarnation because my
incarnation is the biblical incarnation
is not the incarnation that you're
accustomed to that's first of all i was
talking about the son of god and his
eternal
state the son of god who was at the
beginning genesis 1 3 let the light be
so i'm talking about the containment the
rays are the containment of the sun the
father is like the sun su-1 the sun
s-o-n is like the radiance so we can
have contact with the sun by the rays
that touches us the holy spirit is the
heat all the heat the rays you look
above we give honor to the father the
sun suv so the point i'm trying to
establish here again number one you have
to show concealment
let me explain to you why because you're
saying because now we're going to
logical entailment of your your uh uh
your statement you're saying that
eternality can
mingle with time
no i never okay so so if you're not
saying that so it's you have to account
for how if your guidance the sustainer
that means he is engaging with temporal
space please explain to me how the
eternal
integral space so this can engage this
this is the issue this is the problem
because when you ask how can god engage
with temporal space you almost infer
that god is engaging in a physical sense
that he has to physically let me finish
that he has to physically be there to
engage with it for example if i want to
go and engage with you in person i have
to go meet you face-to-face and discuss
and all that i have to be there but god
allah does not need to do that so for
him to engage this is how it works allah
says in the quran like he says about
adam like says about jesus peace be
blessing be upon them they were created
by the word allah said be and they were
that allah says be and it is and you
said you believe that for the creation
god said be and it was we believe that
for the sustenance and the well-being
and anything that occurs that god wills
he says be in it is why does you know
god who exists eternally
have to engage with the universe in a
way where he's
like limiting himself that's the
following that's the false icon i think
you misunderstood my my proposition let
me repeat let me respond to your first
proposition first of all again let's not
make it a matter or a material thing
when i'm saying engagement i said there
are non-materials light
frequencies radio waves so stop making
it a material thing it does not make it
i did that the last time with the jake
the muslim at a physician he kept doing
the same thing material material
material i'm not talking about the
material thing that's first of all
second of all second of all um
uh
i'm saying that the son of god
uh projected himself from his eternal
reality containing his power and the
reason why he needs it
i i understand what you're saying about
your beliefs but i'm asking why is that
proposition that if god wants to engage
with the temporal space he needs to
humble himself true why can't he exist
in the way that muslims believe he
exists that is he's eternal and he
affects temporal space without engaging
in it in a way that needs to humble him
that's the point that you're making so
we both believe a narrative he said let
it be and it was right but we believe
the word of god actually went from his
eternal reality and was projected
outside of his scripture and by that
creating temporal space so the verb
reverberated
into in our reality so the point is the
voice who is the holy spirit according
to scripture no time to give you a
lesson on that and the word was the son
of god so we see both of them engaging
with temporal space in order to create
and to sustain creation so we see the
direct engagement
with
the voice the word and the voice
you can't do that because you're saying
we don't need to do that no no no but if
you're not doing that then there's no
link and there's no link listen bro look
okay i i see
i see what you're saying now i see what
you're saying now this this is the
problem in my opinion right i'm trying
to be humble i'm not just trying to
disagree genuinely logically this is
where i see the problem is you you
you're claiming it as if god needs a
link to the universe where it's kind of
like he needs a passageway to do things
right so he created the passageway
through the son the holy spirit to do
things we're saying god owns it every
particle every ounce of existence
whether it's physical matter dark matter
non-matter whatever it is it's a
contingent thing it's something that is
uh subject to god and again asad is
means the one who doesn't need anything
from anything
but everything that exists depends on
him that it's like master everything in
existence is a servant slave of god and
that he commands them and they don't
have a choice they obey it doesn't need
to be a link in the wait in the sense
that let me go down there and tell them
what's going on tell them what to do
you're misrepresented argument i said
projection so he's still in heaven while
he's protected like the rays of the of
the sun yeah but wait wait wait wait
wait wait
what connected baby i get it i get it
how do you listen listen okay so because
you're misrepresenting argument listen
bro
my point is that you don't need any
projection you don't need anything other
than god willing it because god willing
something is is everything that's
i understand i understand so your point
so we can conclude and then you can
challenge christianity we can conclude
by saying that you have shown no link
between your god and creation
i i've concluded by showing that your
premise is fallacious because it's a
false dichotomy because you you operate
under the narrative that you need some
kind of link whether it's a projection
or it's a staircase to the place where
god sends something to cause things to
happen i'm saying that is fallacious and
it is actually not befitting of god god
being all-powerful should be able to by
definition being unlimited and all
powerful cause something in the universe
without needing a uh kind of projection
or something that like sends a signal to
them he can just will it intend for it
and it happens
so basically again uh to finalize so
basically your god has no link with so
when he says he's the sustainer he's
sustaining it but there's no link he's
the creator this he's the creator
there's no link he he came down and
spoke to moses but if he didn't really
come down because he was outside of
temporal space and he doesn't engage
with temporal space and if he does
engage with temporal space you have to
contain it if no containment then that's
a big problem so
we can leave it there i have no problems
with your
we can agree to disagree um now you can
challenge me on christianity and then we
can finalize like that if you like i
mean to be honest i i don't care enough
to challenge anyone on christianity to
be completely honest i don't want to
like debate or anything you have
something you want to bring okay you
know i want to engage that discussion i
personally don't want to turn it into
debate it's supposed to be something i
don't know i'm just no problem no fears
and i just kind of chill i i agree okay
so uh can i finalize with the last thing
before i leave um i can prove jesus has
submitted all muslims
um okay bro we're not gonna get into
that now man this is not okay no
probably respect really like this is not
problem no problem so until next time i
appreciate the hospitality take care of
yourself man you too man take care
all right at least he was respectful
sorry i didn't read comments for a while
uh
i wasn't in a debate mode but khalas i
mean you know
they people bring it out of me i guess
but alhamdulillah all
i'm going to call you abdullah because i
feel like calling you abdi is
a bit wrong so abdullah inshallah are
you ready to come on man i hope you are
because i'm bringing you on
how are you
you know the crazy thing i actually used
to stay in uh
uae and they always butchered my name
they said my name's up there in somali
but in the uae they call me abdul razak
and they never let it go
have you met loveless hero i love this
no but seriously i have like uh three
important questions
so i'll just get it quick because i
don't want to take up too much of your
time so um
so at least
why did uh allah let a police kind of
let us astray i know the answer but i
just want to hear from you
i mean allah if you think about it
allah
when it comes to like i don't want to
say him versus him versus shaytaan but
when it comes out last month
and what he has done for us versus what
shaytan does
has set us
honestly
set us like straight and is very clear
allah has given us multiple angels
whispering to us to do good telling us
to do good encouraging us to do good and
in one shape on
to try and get us too bad in our nests
that we have allah has sent us the
guidance the quran the son of the
prophet
and uh you know hopefully those around
us as well to guide us to do good so why
did allah allow shaytan to misguide us
is i mean to be honest sometimes asking
why is a bit
troublesome because you can ask why
infinitely right but
because life is a test allah created
this life as a test and
it leads to someone with free will
so he actually as an individual he chose
he wants to misguide this
because his life is a test and what does
allah say in the quran that you will
never misguide my like righteous
believing slaves
that if someone truly righteously
believes in
allah that shaitaan can't bring them
away and that shaitaan will only ever
actually misguide someone who is who
would have been misguided i would say
regardless when allah says that does
that also apply to someone like let's
say
someone falls into a certain sin or some
certain lifestyle and they come out of
that is that a righteous person that is
also
you know coming back or is it just
exclusive
a person that doesn't send and repents
and comes back
yes
i mean i mean it's up to allah to decide
who is truly righteous but it is a
righteous act to ask for tawba look at
adam
they committed the sin and they allah
actually taught them how to make tawbah
they made it
yeah thank you for answering i have two
more questions so i actually was uh born
in uh the united states i was born in um
virginia but i actually was raised here
to like four then i moved to the middle
east and then around the age of 10 11 i
came back to the us
and then
i studied here then i went back to dubai
and africa and then i came back from
high school and then on to college here
so i was going to ask you like
how was your experience moving here if
you moved here
i i was born here actually
i mean i say alhamdulillah but i don't
know if it's a good thing just hamdullah
for everything but i was born here so i
can't really say there's a transition or
anything um but i do understand it can
be difficult
um
there are unfortunate places in the
middle east that are maybe even worse
than here in terms of socially
but
yeah it's as someone who's lived here it
is difficult
uh because you feel like an outsider
someone who wants islam to triumph
someone yeah i was gonna say your point
about you know sometimes
i've actually seen some in the middle
east it's actually more you know like
it's more wild than some places in like
america you know some americans are
actually more conservative than you know
arabs nowadays and yeah and i swear it's
actually crazy i was thinking about that
recently and uh
yeah it's just a good point you made
yeah
and uh my final question is um basically
like you know i know
it is from
bangladesh bangladesh and uh
hell is from puerto rico and you're from
palestine masha'allah so palestine
and uh i was gonna say
that
for you because i always try to put
myself in other people's shoes and in
their struggles so how is that for you
knowing that like your family your
cousins
you know we're at one omaha but you know
it's different for you because you know
you actually know people
in the situation in palestine and how
does that affect you on a day-to-day
and how do you kind of cope with it and
what's what's your connection have you
been there and i also
last part as an american citizen i don't
want to you know support israel but i
want to visit how do i do that
i don't want to give them any dollars
yeah i i don't know if there's any way
other than flying to jordan and then
entering across the border jordanian
israeli border um other than that i
don't know you might just have to like
go fly to tel aviv i don't know if
there's any other way to really enter um
and my relationship bro well it's
heartbreaking it makes me very angry um
but i mean it's been going on since i
was born man like i grew up i grew up
with my you know family members crying
watching videos about you know what
happens in philistine it's just it's
something that
i
i i don't say i'm desensitized to it but
it's like
you see someone get beat up enough times
it's like it doesn't shock you anymore
you know what i mean
and just last question have you been
back there and that's it for me thank
you so much
have you i haven't a lot bless you bro
but i haven't been to philosophy
inshallah one day
all right
we have a super chat thank you for the
ten dollars uh christians believe one
plus one plus one equals one ridiculous
i know muslims know that there is only
one god and one equals one
i'm no muslim but i know that there is a
higher power slash consciousness
it's self-evident
why not make us good
well
i mean it depends could god have created
us in a way where we can't do anything
wrong we can only do that which is good
100
uh but then life wouldn't be a test you
wouldn't have evil you'd only have good
and we we would be angels because god
made a creation like that they're the
angels that they obey allah and
everything that he says and they never
disobey him they do everything basically
perfectly as allah commands that's it
allah intended differently for human
beings that we have desires that we have
free will that we have
guidance from allah that we should
choose to act upon but we can choose to
basically basically act against it do
what's wrong and if we decide to do
what's wrong we know very well that we
will be punished for it
so
uh why not make us good i mean that's a
question that only god himself can truly
answer
but
there wouldn't be a test there wouldn't
be heaven there wouldn't be hell there
wouldn't be any of that in the end
and when the angels kind of asked god a
similar question
they said hey basically allah said i
know that which you don't know
so allah knows the best at the end of
the day and i'm not answering with allah
knows the best i'm finishing with allah
knows best but i hope my answer was
satisfactory to to an extent there would
be no good basically
long story short there if everything was
good there would be no good because
that's just what everything is there'd
be no evil there'd be no good
so the thing the statement itself is
kind of self-defeating you know what i
mean
um
but it's it's still it's a good question
it's obviously a lot of people are
curious about it which is it's fine it's
good it's just uh we need to kind of be
open-minded and have these discussions
so thank you for the uh the question
it's a good question masha'allah
all right
um
i'm gonna bring two people on try and
make it fast insha'allah
uh and i'm gonna remove the sister hadid
lover
uh you guys can join back in sha allah
in the actual youtube
uh video
so youtube
and i'm gonna bring on dean over dunya
first and then insha'allah afterwards um
this next brother and then just chill
and end it as you guys can see i'm a
little like spaced out but salaam
alaikum dean over dunya
muted
or maybe they stepped away
like
all right my friend sammy you're about
to come on man hope you're ready
all right so now i'm
wait i wasn't
i was actually taking notes
studying
but
what was it the point about israel
um the fact that we opposed zionism and
not judaism
right
yeah what are your thoughts on that
that we oppose zionism not judaism yeah
let's and i not zionism in general like
if if jewish people want a right to
their own state that's fine
but the political zionism that exists
today with
the state the nation of israel for the
sovereign nation of israel and the idf
that's what we we oppose
because the result of such a thing is
murder genocide ethnic cleansing and
complete disregard
for human rights dignity a complete
disregard and a complete breaking of the
rules of the declaration of human rights
that everyone i believe including israel
signed
and
led to war crimes atrocities like i said
ethnic cleansing so that's what we
oppose the political
um
zionism that we see
and another thing
backed a bit to sports
uh
you see
mma and martial arts are becoming sort
of more prominent in the east is that a
cultural thing what does religion sort
of have to do with it like it's
grappling
oh yeah right wrestling wrestling the
sunnah that sahabah used to wrestle the
process and even wrestled at one point
one one of the best wrestlers actually
challenged the prophet islam to a
wrestling match he's like you know i can
take this guy he's not that big you know
russell sent me his average height
average build so this guy's probably
like you know big like you know i could
take him whatever process telling me
threw him down like nothing he's done
and he's like no i wasn't ready man come
on i you know i slipped on on a rock
let's go again
the second time
took him down
i believe he did it three times as well
and the man just kind of was like
whatever man he walked away so it is
some no
so yeah i'm going to give
the
space for someone else like to give a
new
if someone's in cube
yeah thanks man
that's what we like man go to brothers
and good sisters mashallah like what
we've had on so far
uh dean over dunya this is your last
chance in sha allah
you're muted i don't know if you're here
or not
uh brother or sister if you don't speak
in three seconds i'm gonna boot you off
three
two
one
and
type all right
all right bismillah let's get back to
comments i'm gonna end it soon maybe
take a few more comments and go i'm a
little half-minded i don't know why
um
but alhamdulillah regardless
no bro we i mean
i mean if you think about it
we probably like jews more than like you
know i don't want to say we like jews
more than atheists because you know
there are good atheists bad atheists or
good jewish people bad jewish people
good muslims bad muslims and people who
claim to be atheist jewish and muslim
so i don't want to say one group is
better but the jews are the people of
the book they believe in god
i mean there are a lot of jews actually
that are atheists which believe it or
not sounds crazy but it's true
unfortunately there's a lot of jews that
are atheists believe it or not but
um
that aside you know the people of the
book and
we love that the prophet when he was
shown the the torah he said that this is
a good book
so
rejection is not supposed to be
something that's harsh it's a reject if
anything rejection should be kind
because the projection is harsh then
it's just you're just being mean
if you're going to reject someone at
least say it nicely
unless they deserve it harshly you know
like if a guy is like actively pursuing
a girl and she's annoys it okay be harsh
but like get the hell on my face man i'm
gonna call my brother
that's okay
organize i'm gonna head here for the
brothers but i need someone to organize
it for me man i'm not the one to
organize it uh i don't know what i'm
doing with that but insha'allah
inshallah it's
a beautiful thing
beautiful thing and i hope insha'allah
we can i love when the brothers you know
organize that for for um kind of groups
to go and do um
it's beautiful may allah grant us the
ability to do hajj
i mean
life is rough us modern day youth are
sensitive ones 100
that is true man unfortunately but
alhamdulillah
allah gives you strength you know
guidance
level-headedness clear-headedness
everything that is here it comes from
allah
you have to work for it but it comes
from allah
beer tips get a derma roller not the
long bristle one but the short one and
then as you can see my beer is not fully
in yet either but um roll it
and then put
beard oil
that's meant to grow your beard because
their beard oils just yeah you know for
like making it look good making it smell
good
but get one to actually grow your beard
inshallah
i don't know how many times people are
going to ask this question insha allah
hamza
lovely brother the episode with him will
drop
in a few weeks insha allah
to be honest
um
i can't think of a team other than the
leafs and the the penguins
honestly
i'm a failed canadian i had an ice cap
this whole time
and i i didn't drink it
that's so sad
but for hajj you need the job oh yeah
yeah
yes i said bismillah in my head no one
come after me
and uh if you guys think this is my left
hand it's actually my right hand i just
flipped the camera
just so you know
coffee or tea coffee
uh
every day i read the quran and learn
something new i'm in my second read it's
my life handbook
i watched a video of two people actually
trying to discuss how useless the quran
is random out of order like they'd
rather read like harry potter or
something it's like habibi okay maybe if
you're trying to entertain yourself
it's not supposed to
be entertaining it's not entertainment
right this is the problem with with uh
liberalism that you have to just do
things that make you feel good entertain
you and
get you a dopamine spike and
habibi
we don't read the quran for
entertainment like we read
lord of the rings or something
we read the quran as a guide for life
we read the quran to find answers in
life
because the most naive person thinks
that they have everything figured out
i think that's all i need to say on it
for now
don't come out lord of the rings
i haven't read it so i can't say
anything about it to be honest
alhamdulillah
what is the plural form of ipv well it's
so funny you're asking me that because i
was in a group of guys and i said happy
bats because i don't speak arabic so i'm
like happy bats and that's actually the
plural for for women
so my bad
my bad
hey bit confused you said it a few days
ago you don't speak arabic but you're
always singing in arabic at the end
surah muslim
so i i recite the quran
in arabic because i memorized like you
know how you know some words in french
you know some words in spanish you know
some words in different languages maybe
if you watch anime you know a few words
in japanese
right
i
listened to recitations of the quran
and learned how to say the words like
alhamdulillah i know how to say some
arabic words i'm just not fluent in it
and i can't really read or write
properly
so
i don't speak arabic but i do have some
words in the arabic language memorized
and these words are the words of the
quran
chapters from the quran that god himself
has revealed
so alhamdulillah
that was such a cute mistake they said
uh sing sing and sing in arabic
it's reciting that
all right
yes
quran is easy to memorize even me i'm
not arab but i know somehow
that's the thing about
arabic or about the quran
arabic is a beautiful language and the
quran is so clear and concise and
and uh easy to memorize because it's
short because it's clear and concise and
short it's easy to memorize
rami make your background pink
i'll make my i'll make my background
pink here
there
just for you
i hear how there's two like
really white spots here
but
inshallah
favorite reciter
salman yutibi
do you say about pronouns that some
people making for themselves i mean i
don't say anything about them i don't i
think they're baseless they're based on
emotion how people feel
um
that's all i really can say about it we
don't practice that in islam
said he created man and women he created
man and their spouse
that's it
it's uh i forget the brand but it's a
floodlight flood
light i didn't know there were a thing
until recently and this is a uh i talked
about this on my last stream this is a
projector screen it just like it kind of
soaks up the light
nicely
three lessons
that you've learned
being on youtube
um
everything you do matters everything you
say matters
everything is
important um
what you say even what you don't say
subhanallah even what you don't say is
important
especially when with really you know
touchy subjects
i know what you're talking
about um
well i i i know i make mistakes
even in this stream i'm worried that i
said something that might not fully be
true when i said that allah
only allows shaytan to really misguide
people that kind of would have been
misguided
because they're not you know they don't
want to humble themselves allah i don't
know i take that back i don't know if
that's true
i think it's true but i don't know that
is true and well that's what worries me
that's you know saying something that's
wrong
uh well hold on man it's scary may allah
protects me allah forgive me
but uh
those two things are probably the
biggest i can't think of a third to be
honest
and muslims are
both acting in good faith why can't
muslims and christians unite against the
common enemy that is liberalism you know
what honestly that'd be amazing that'd
be great
that would be great uh
go against capitalism go against
secularism go against liberalism that
would be amazing but the problem is when
christians
with all due respect to them when they
were basically the state
uh people hated their life
people hated it and that's why
secularism
secularism
came to be
because they were basically making
things up as they go because it wasn't
based on the bible
like martin luther
he read the bible
when he got his hands on it and he
basically left the church after that
but i do agree that you know they should
unite christians and muslims should
unite on what they agree on
so i'm going to take one more comment
shalom i'm going to end this stream
problem christianity submitted to
liberalism already you know actually
that's that's technically true yeah
but i don't think christianity is
inherently inherently uh
a secular religion or supposed to be a
secular religion but i don't know i'm
not christian
i'm going to challenge you in arabic
language next live inshallah so i won't
bring you on next live inshallah
i'll ban you from the stream
oh god i have my i make a fool of myself
enough in front of my arabic teacher i
don't need to i don't need to bring that
stuff online
with that being said inshallah i'm going
to end the stream here
allah says in the quran
foreign